what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are gonna celebrate
this summer with a Thanksgiving episode
I'm assuming it's called two turkeys for
Brooklyn nine nine John how are you I am
turktastic G I'm ready to get stuffed
how are you gobble gobble leave a like
ladies and Gentlemen let's get into
action and as always though really quick
full interaction watch along music with
zero copy of Brooklyn nine nine Bill the
first super sexy Rejects at a patreon
page thank you to all who have joined
especially for this show alone cover
several things over there exclusively
with Direction highlights and watch
songs included now let's gobble
Tommy Gobbler's back and he wants to
hear what you turkeys are thankful for
Charles you gotta stop
is this tail on the elevator dude gobble
gobble gobble your tail feather is
caught in a gobble door thank you gobble
wait what
I think your feathers are ripping gobble
gobble yep
[Laughter]
[Music]
classic Charles are there police
stations where the elevator takes you
right to it this whole time I've never
questioned that yeah elevator just takes
you right into the right into the
bullpen
it's the most efficient station you've
been living and breathing this operation
for years it goes down today and we only
get one shot Thanksgiving 2017 the
meeting of the parents here we go when
the time is right our fathers will share
a goodbye and it will be weird but in
the good way oh my God nice first we
have the santiagos Camila and Victor
they are traditional reserved and like
their daughter controlling I would say
I'm Type A you should write type A there
instead of controlling Vivid example hey
I have the Peraltas Karen and Roger they
are a perfectly normal no known flaws
all right fine my dad's a selfish
drunken [__] my mom's a flighty weird
this is gonna be a disaster a list of
things they have in common we can use it
to grease the conversation okay our dads
both golf our moms both paint all four
of them have hair yeah but that's bottom
of the barrel stuff We're not gonna have
to use that it's gonna be amazing
absolutely
holding it from the bottom true maybe
it's a cheesecake there's no
condensation on the box it's room
temperature look at the fingers spread
tensing in the shoulders he's supporting
something dense it's a pie it is a pie
damn that was impressive I should have
said pie I was thinking pie because
Thanksgiving it's also Ava's birthday so
we do it up huge I got her a period of
pair that's a hot toy Terry tried 10 toy
stores I guess I'm the only one doing
this holiday right hitting the open road
with my bike yes well everyone's plans
soon lovely oh Hitchcock and I didn't
say harsh how unfortunate
oh that's rude Kevin that's why no one
likes you Kevin dad you almost ready the
santiagos are very punctual
they're here oh no honey I know you're
nervous tuck your shirt in Peralta yeah
and you brought a turkey even though I
told her that you were making the turkey
and also need to bring with stuffing the
stuffing's inside it and now we have two
turkeys just in case in case of what I
don't know
yeah Care Bear which pants do you think
honey the Santiago's are here Felice
thanks let's get out all over again the
squad well Ben now is everything okay
sir no I went to a meeting and when I
returned my pie was gone
calm down there's no need to point
fingers at us it was clearly a Hitchcock
and Scully how dare you you have no
proof there's crumbs all over your desk
whoever took the pie come forward and
all will be forgiven you know I would
never forgive you but your dog if you
think I won't get to the bottom of this
everyone here is a suspect
damn convo Greece combo grease them
right now yes Mrs Peralta I love this
new ceramic that you painted my mom
paints as well I paint on canvases
though oh and that's different very
completely
the canvas is my canvas she said canvas
so much who wants to hear a joke you
mean like a riddle because I love
riddles I know I mean like a joke joke
where I say it and you laugh
hahaha
Jake you're remembering when he used to
pretend to golf so that he could spend
his Sundays cheating on me oh yeah oops
but it's okay now we're happy we're back
together cool
he's so great
hair
we all have hair
my dad is super competitive too it's bad
he got kicked off a bird watching tour
once look a kingfisher no no no no no
that's the same bird I saw earlier that
doesn't count
why can't there be some magic potion
that makes everyone happy and have fun
all the time
some alcohol
[Music]
by the book the security camera in my
office was obscured which means whoever
took my pie thought it through that
means it wasn't Hitchcock and Scully
exactly now as for you three I think
it's time we had a little chat why just
them three
not mine no don't tell me why you did it
tell him you want me to talk to this
picture of your husband look at me eye
and tell him what you did I Didn't Do It
Kevin don't you say his name
I was at the grocery store buying Goose
feet for nikolaj's dinner I was at the
gym Ava's birthday Thanksgiving dinner
is a high caloric Affair everybody has
an alibi how convenient and none of you
were at work we need the room to
question someone about the Red Hook
homicide oh no problem we'll be right up
my mom's telling a story about my birth
and your parents are not recoiling it's
good let's keep it going I think we need
top them off I top them off they're
gonna get so wasted good morning I do
what I'm told but yet I cannot Escape
your school what am I an alarm clock oh
yeah so a riddle is just like a fact
that's told me a really confusing way
exactly
it's Allen Burger well he did wasn't
amazing between us I could have landed
that plane on the ground at the
destination without killing any of those
birds is my had playing piano and is my
dad
[Music]
[Laughter]
in fact I think everyone here has had
enough we have yes now we're drinking
this
room
oh you should have bust that out first
you guys are gonna get sick YouTube it's
not real alcohol they're actors
pretending Jesus it's water and apple
juice here's what we need from you a
list of the pies ingredients we're
looking for anything that might Linger
on someone's breath we need surveillance
footage from the water fountain the
crumb consistency was dry whoever ate
it's going to be thirsty now what kind
of crimped Edge are we Camilla and I are
thrilled to welcome you into our family
so allow me to be the first to bless
this Union with a toast to Jake and amen
you're here I have a toast too oh Karen
and I would like to welcome you into our
family and allow me to be the first to
say that it's gonna confessions round
two oh that seems like plenty days no
Victor gets too toast then I would like
to go one step further and say that if
there is anything that you need or want
[Laughter]
it's a lot better than yours Jake I give
you my grandfather's watch you are now a
Santiago I would like to pay for the
wedding Amy you are now my daughter
[Laughter]
who can I interest in 12 cups of coffee
no I'd like to know what Roger meant
when he said he would pay for the
wedding you know his tradition for the
bride's family to pay it's also
tradition oh really we appreciate the
offer but we're paying no you gave him
the watch that was your gift maybe we
should just split the wedding it's a
great idea given your financial
situation
it's dinner time everybody go wash your
hands Amy you come with me this is worse
than my sixth birthday party when I
caught my dad making out with a female
clown in the bounce house oh he's
ruining the whole day
yeah you're dead too yep yeah you have
to pretend like he's cool those are the
rules plus you gotta admit your parents
were being a little condescending
because they asked what was in the dip
that seemed to be just Mayo all dip is
just Mayo your mom brought her own hand
towels as if my mom wouldn't have washed
hers knowing they had guests coming over
did she no you don't have to they're
only touched by freshly Clean Hands they
never get dirty wow she keeps I know
that my parents aren't going to ruin any
joysness in fact they're going to be
Joyce's help not nearly as Joyce as my
parents I checked into your Alibis or
should I say I'll obliged
why is your tank only half full you
dipsticked my bike that's not all like
dipsticks shall I call you by your real
name Mr FIB I find it quite awesome
and your gym is closed on Thanksgiving
and Boyle about buying Goose feed for
Nikolas they were all in it together but
there was one purchase a beverage that
pairs perfectly with pie one gallon of
milk no three people lady dipstick Mr
fib and the Milkman The Jig Is up Okay I
lied thank you not about the pie about
my Thanksgiving spending with my family
we're seeing the new minions Musical on
Broadway I was picking up these matching
t-shirts for my whole family I missed my
family a lot when I was in prison and
we've gotten really close again t-shirts
were my idea
wow I lied about the gym because I was
still trying to find a Perry to Parrot
for Ava I forgot it was her birthday
coming up by the time I realize
I'm drinking milk all he eats is
Buttered Noodles
pie I wish he hates nuts I my son is the
basic [__] oh no so we expanded the
search radius my pie and it wasn't even
eaten just thrown away like Common
Street trash spend your life on the
force and it never gets easier Kevin who
would throw it out I feel like it's
Gotta Be Kevin I don't know why though I
don't know maybe he doesn't like the pie
we have turkeys you get both car
s thank goodness for the second turkey
everybody could see who cuts the turkey
better wow really mature I'm just saying
that because you know my dad's gonna win
I know that Peraltas aren't perfect but
we don't look down on other people I
mean you come into our home and you act
like we're idiots well we're not idiots
in fact I just there it is
[Applause]
bad
my father cut his thumb up we need help
right now do you have the thumb yeah I
got it right here okay just fill out
these forms someone will be within a bit
you have three half-sisters what one in
Atlanta one in New York one in Dallas
Fort Worth all the hubs
I love you candy machine Victor that was
amazing thank you so much for coming are
on their way they're still cleaning up
all the blood yeah they were so much
they might have to move I'm really sorry
about all the things I said
look I love you and is that still your
dance though oh my God yes he needs this
nurse
trying to cover up your dark secrets for
there was one other person who you even
better than out playing scone we're in
school
he has nothing better than a plane scone
this is ridiculous look at how the pie
was disposed of placed gently with two
hands inside the bin that's exactly how
you always throw away garbage why'd you
do it because it's disgusting that pie
is an Abomination I don't know why we
can't still make the drive next year we
just don't have to buy the pie trip with
no purpose Raymond
mom's already tuckered out yeah you know
how tired she gets when she drinks she
won't be up for 12 hours I had five
brothers Three Sisters four aunts and 12
cousins who spent every holiday together
I had the kind of family that you dream
of oh are you done that seemed like a
really mean place to stop
ouch
what it means to have a big family and
apparently my family is a lot bigger
than I thought how many half-sisters did
you say I have Dad I only told you about
the sisters come on uh being so
defensive are you wanting to pay for the
wedding I'm sorry too I was just feeling
insecure because I did take the watch I
was gonna say because you saw my penis
through my but the watch yeah sure
you're a good dude come here give me a
hug bring it in Jake it's happening
best Thanksgiving ever yep dad your
grandma's riding up it's out oh it's out
you ever seen your dad's drunk
I think probably at some point in my
life not many times but I I have a
feeling it's happened yeah
cool
I saw your dad's jokes
me yeah
and he was wearing shorts
and he wasn't wearing underwear I don't
think so he did a big stretch back on a
park learning this on camera that looked
at the wrong time that's hilarious
sounds like my dad he's dead now you be
respectful
I'm sure he's laughing about that and
he's got a dead dad you could always
call that card yeah I'm so sorry I owe
you for the rest of my life
bringing me up this insensitive story oh
that's fine it sounds like my dad
anyway that was fun that was really fun
yeah that was super duper fun I feel
festive
um
Jimmy Smits and uh it was really the
dads they saw the show yeah Jeremy
Spence and Bradley Woodford they were
hilarious they were so funny it was like
watching two veteran actors duel each
other yeah it was they were both Jeepers
wasn't that funny his last appearance he
was mainly there to
um antagonize right yeah be the dad here
try to play please yeah well playing to
he's a straight man to Jake's foil
so I thought that they them together was
hilarious like it was a perfect
escalation of starting off with them
having tension and then listening up and
having fun and how it like they they
found a natural way to get to the things
they set up or where it could possibly
go down and became a kind of an
unexpected way uh I thought it just
escalated and built into this game with
tops really well and then overall it's
all a wrap around to it that was really
funny that was hilarious yeah absolutely
yeah like both sides of the episode I
mean like the heart and soul is all the
Thanksgiving stuff and yeah just
watching them duel and I mean I I liked
um uh the the moms as well uh Katie
Seagal and the actress whose name I
don't know
um but yeah I mean it's it's it's just
their show at a certain point it makes
me wonder you know because too I mean
obviously these shows are are planned
out and scripted but there's also you
know everybody on the cast is good with
improv so I wonder if any of that was
them kind of riffing and playing off
each other and whatnot because it has
that spun uh spontaneous kind of energy
and uh I mean brother woodford's worked
with like Aaron Sorkin for a gazillion
years sure he's got that Rhythm too oh
yeah absolutely he can handle a lot of
tile I'm paying for the wedding you're
my daughter
yeah it's like great deliveries across
the board and and the game of tops they
engage in is like well uh crafted and uh
and yeah just the the dueling
thanksgivings and then two on the
opposite side of the episode I I enjoyed
I mean you know you know it's not gonna
be one of them
kind of deep down but I did like the way
that yeah it's like you got Hitchcock
and Scully is like the most obvious uh
culprits for this who then are a given
like I like anytime Hitchcock and Scully
are given some kind of weird reason to
actually take charge and really show
their narrow field of prowess uh and
yeah all like the interrogations with
Rosa and Boyle and Terry this is like a
really fun game on the other side of the
episode as well nicely proportioned
episode I didn't feel like one you know
it's like the main the centerpiece is
the Thanksgiving dinner that's most of
what you do but I thought the cutting
back to the precinct was also a fun you
know way to also do a Thanksgiving story
that's not just a dinner again
yeah it's had that sketch quality
element that I really like where it
still feels shot within the genre yeah
it doesn't feel like I'm watching
um that feels like an artifice it feels
very real yeah but like a hide in
reality you know like if the commitment
is just through the roof that you're
just having a blast
yeah the interrogation is really fun
even even the moments with Kevin at the
end were like funny too yeah totally
everything still felt within characters
like they didn't ever do anything that
seemed to give up who the characters
were or just only leaned into a gimmick
of the character they managed to make it
still feel like nuanced with everyone
and even right down to the reveals of
what they were all really up to yeah
after their allies I was like oh yeah
that's
it actually lines up with Emma's
characters even though it's telling of
like secrets that were harboring I
thought were really funny yeah and like
the fact that too they have to
you know I mean they've established
certain characters as better Liars than
others but yeah it's like the matter of
the fact is nobody did take the pie even
though they are all hiding something
else and so it's like you can tell when
they're pleading their innocence that
they're being sincere yeah and so yeah
that just makes for like a nice sort of
tension to the game and then you had to
have it come around to do that like they
they do a lot of things where they'll
hide like a little tell in something
that holds or Kevin says and yeah that
plane scone line stuck out to me because
obviously it is a joke but at the same
time I love that it comes back to that
like nothing's better than a plain scope
you know kind of reminded me of that
whole thing about like Captain hold
doesn't use contractions you know as the
tell from that previous episode with the
gambling uh yeah and and and two I like
that that thing with Kevin and Holt
ended on a positive note rather than
them having some kind of stuff yeah
exactly I don't know it could easily go
down a more sort of angry path and I
like that it it comes it dovetails
around to like I love these trips so
much and and maybe we could just take a
trip
without needing to get the pie yeah you
know and that's sort of leading to not
only a resolve but like an extra spark
for the relationship
nice deep
yeah there was a lot of great things in
there I even loved it in Thanksgiving
part where uh Amy and Jake started
turning each other naturally where sides
start to happen because that's
such a real real relationship thing to
play on where you know how like like
just unbearable your own parents are and
how embarrassing they can be but then
you stick up defensive for them yeah
yeah I'm allowed to dog on them but you
have to yeah that whole thing about like
you have to pretend like they're super
cool is like I think that's a very real
thing to have yeah and like having to
feeling like you two are together in
this but also having this sort of tiptoe
around your allegiances yeah great
little tension Builder as well that was
really funny that was really that was
really really funny yeah
um liked it a lot these holiday episodes
often shine
do some type of game it's usually like a
game of sorts yes sure and like while
there was a game of tops it wasn't like
a game of Investigation they're they're
not playing there's no contest here yeah
you know there's no Heist or there's no
like oh there's like a Precinct party
that has some kind of yeah like
structural element to it it is just like
everyone's just trying to celebrate
Thanksgiving you know yeah
yeah have you heard of the show called
suits yes I have heard of it I don't
really know much about it is it a lawyer
show yeah I
um
was eating dinner
and then Netflix stopped on a clip like
you know how sometimes they set up a
trailer they play a clip yeah
and I I didn't know this show and
there's like eight seasons I'm like what
is this and there was it was uh
I played the clip and I was like hmm
so I decided to watch they decided to
watch the pilot and be like and it was
like a two-part pilot so it's really
long
it's pretty great yeah okay in fact in
recent I've heard some people bring it
up actually funny I'm nearing the end of
Psych some people have been like you
should check out suit snakes check out
suits I was like really there's their
suits fans out there but but yeah eight
seasons of Suits Me So It's gotta be a
big show is it uh is that the one with
Mark Paul Gossler
single actor I don't know any of their
names okay is it the woman the guy from
Saved by the Bell and the guy from
Clueless no idea or is that Franklin and
Bash or something
black girl who's a lawyer in it too okay
I'm just gonna google suits really she's
like more of a veteran actress oh cool
I think or I'm just aging up actress
who's still young and upcoming
yeah it's that show okay yeah it's uh I
think that's the guy from the spirit I
think that's Gabriel mock oh that makes
sense yeah oh cool I'll have to give it
a look-see
yeah it was really fun I'm excited to
hear that
anyway it's the first thing I've heard
about suits
I don't know other than its existence I
didn't know anything about it because I
saw some clip and I was like oh cool
clip let me let me see the chair I'm
glad the system works usually usually
I'm like stop Netflix just let me just
let me look a lot of times it takes a
good clip to get me that's how love is
blind made me started I was like huh
interesting clip
sometimes I work that works way better
for me than trailer most of the time
alrighty guys well thank you so much for
being here
um we will chit chat with you all soon
tell us tell us your favorite
Thanksgiving what year was it oh yeah
that's a specific question you're not
going to take the time to think about it
type but go forward
1998. see you guys